[Music]
all right joining us now with reaction
so tonight's breaking news or opening
monologue he is a former US Attorney for
the District of Columbia Jodi Jennifer
Fox News contributor Andrew McCarthy and
of course he writes for National Review
to the smartest people I know good to
see you so struck gets to go behind
closed doors he says he's gonna talk and
I don't believe it
well he probably is gonna talk Sean
because he talked to Horowitz so you
know I think he sounds like he's one of
these guys who thinks he can go into the
room and kind of control the room and
the Horowitz says that that when he's
really arrogant and stupid well Horowitz
said that he had very long involved
answers on every question he asked about
you know why'd you do this why'd you do
that so he may just be one of these guys
who thinks he can go into that
environment and do okay and he's got
reasons to think that because in a
courtroom where there's a judge somebody
can't get away with just giving their
side of the story and then saying when
you try to cross-examine I'm oh national
security reasons or you know
investigative integrity a judge would
tell them no no you told your side of
the story now they get to ask you about
the hard stuff in a congressional
hearing you can dodge that stuff I mean
they get away with that all the time I
have some faith in a few of the
congressmen there Jordan gates
some of the people Sarah was talking
about you know you know one thing you
said Joe to Jennifer that still sticks
with me because so many in my family my
mom was a prison guard my dad worked in
family court probation I had cousins
that were on the NYPD the two guys that
were diety were both FBI guys and you
say bad cop and sadly it's true and he
was the lead guy interviewed Clinton
interviewed Flynn began the russia'
investigation which I would argue
renders it illegitimate from the get-go
this is the guy you're talking about
this is one of the guys not the
rank-and-file guys yeah well as I said
from the very beginning of this James
Comey was a dirty cop and Mister struct
is dirtier the bottom line is very
simple he's going to go in tomorrow and
he's gonna lie he's going to give
explanations that are untruthful
he says that when Lisa Paige asked him
he's not him speaking about president
candidate Trump he can't win Kenny we
can't have him as president and struck
says no no no we'll stop it now he is
claiming that there's an explanation for
we'll stop it I can't wait to hear it
you know you have two people that I
don't think I want to mess with in a
courtroom
I kind of agree but then there's the
insurance policy then there's your
lonesome human being then there's you
know beyond we'll stop but then there's
the actions now it's real this is real
and I'm you know some superior belief
that he's doing it you know for noble
causes really he's almost attempting a
coup because somebody was guilty of
crimes he pushes under the rug and then
they go full force sledgehammer on the
other candidate you know to me it's
influencing an election and Clinton
let's just let's just be very clear
about this this is not a complicated
case the FBI at the senior levels in the
Obama administration and the Department
of Justice Loretta Lynch and all her
minions had two goals in mind very
simple very plain exonerate Hillary
Clinton illegally and then if she lost
the election to frame Donald Trump
that's it it's it's in a nutshell it's
never changed over the last two years
and everything that we have learned from
the text messages the IG reports etc has
proven conclusively that that is
precisely with James Comey and Loretta
Lynch and the Obama administration
people wanted to do and it was the most
brazen plot in the history of US law
enforcement and it won't make much
difference unless we get all the facts
out on the table and I agree this look I
think it's clear that these were two
investigations that were going on at the
same time and whether you're a liberal
or conservative
Republican or Democrat I don't know how
you look at them and say that the same
quality of justice was accorded to to
both but you know equal justice under
the law equal application of our laws
our constitutional system here listen it
all started with Hillary she committed
felonies the biggest most obvious case
of obstruction they made every
consideration throughout every needle
even though other people went to jail
for far worse and then you go to what
they did to Donald Trump what what Joe's
talking about then how do you lie to a
FISA judge Andy not once four times
unverified uncorroborated against the
law against FBI protocol four times
using bought and paid for political
research from an outside or a foreign
national Shawn I think on one side of
the coin with Hillary it looks like they
bent over backwards to not make the case
in the face of mountainous evidence
against her and on the other side where
you don't have evidence of a crime it
seems that they scorched the earth to
try to stop this presidency that to me
is an attempted bypassing the will of
the American people and you're right Joe
and it really when you get down to the
brass tacks here it's a simple case a
simple case of the abuse of power far
deeper than anything we ever imagined
with Watergate and corruption in my
opinion now here's the simple fact what
the FBI and the DOJ in the Obama
administration did was subversion no
plain and simple this is 1954 communist
stuff subversion they sought to subvert
the the an election and when the person
that they didn't want got elected they
sought to subvert his presidency they
have done everything in their power and
don't forget even though struck is
testifying tomorrow the guy who started
all of this was John Brennan the CIA
director in cooperation with clapper
none of this will be fair unless both of
them finds themselves in front of a
grand jury last for dandy I think he'll
a lot to say tomorrow behind closed
doors but I still he do let the text
speak for themselves should they release
the transcript Congress has the power to
make that the chairman of the power soon
as they scrub it to I assume they're
asking him questions behind closed doors
because they may get into classified
matters but I think as soon as they can
scrub that it shouldn't I can't they do
what they often do which is they do some
in public and then whatever they need to
ask I hope I hope that's what they are
going to do I think Jim Jordan said he
regards this as step one so I think this
is step one and then there'll be a
public hearing I think there will be
people to go to jail and I think it's
the worst abuse of power we've ever seen
and I think it's gonna get worse based
on what people tell me thank you
great work on NRO Joe you're always so
shy we really need you to come out of
your shell a little bit more just a hair
Joe digenova thank you